foreign
should be concerned about this because
you could be a victim you could be
someone who's cash whose car whose home
gets seized in order to support These
funds and if the federal government is
spending billions of dollars to do it
that means they're spending billions of
dollars to Target someone just like you
my name is Dan Albin I'm a senior
Attorney At The Institute for justice
and I co-direct our national initiative
to end forfeiture abuse civil forfeiture
allows the government to take and
permanently keep your property without
ever even charging you with a crime
between 2000 and 2019 the federal
government brought in over 45 billion
dollars in forfeiture Revenue
Federal forfeiture is a big business and
it's a particularly big business for the
law enforcement agencies that get to
spend the money out of these funds and
in order to ensure that they maximize
the number of forfeitures they hire a
number of private Consultants to assist
with everything from investigations to
record keeping to processing and all the
paperwork that that needs to be
completed in order to do this process
and so the federal government recently
issued over six billion dollars in
contracts for a five-year period for
private contractors to assist with the
federal forfeiture process and the fact
that they're spending six billion
dollars I think highlights what kind of
big business this is you probably heard
the adage you've got to spend money to
make money here it's you've got to spend
money to take money and in order to
seize and forfeit as much property as
they can and put as much of that money
into these forfeiture slush funds law
enforcement recognizes that they need to
hire private contractors to help them
maximize how much property they're
seizing from ordinary Americans and
putting into their own coffers
foreign
[Music]